natural live chat thank you um good
evening everybody I'd like to welcome
you to this strategy and resources
committee which is a continuation of the
meeting from the 26th of January
2023 in Open Session
um before we start with the main agenda
items I'm going to invite councilor
fluka to correct some information that
he's provided during the earlier session
on the 26th of January and then after
this I'll take apologies
thank you chairman um really I'm just
going to correct what I say for the
benefit of the record
um chairman at the last meeting I I um
reported that the the total current
assets of the citizens advice Bureau had
risen from 147 000 to 155 000 pounds
chairman and that they had 14 part-time
staff and one member of staff was
receiving sixty thousand pounds a year
um chairman that was incorrect
um I think I wouldn't have made a
mistake I think if more information had
been supplied on the evening and I know
that Miss Green's here tonight and I'm
sure that when this matter goes to
Council in two weeks time the members
will be fully informed and I rather hope
that
um the
um the cab actually provide management
accounts up to at least December of last
year and and I think it would be
beneficial as well uh chairman if we had
to list the statutory duties that see a
b can perform so in summary chairman my
reference to sixty thousand pounds as
one member of Staff being paid was
incorrect and I apologize to to council
and I apologize citizens advice bureau
if it's caused any problems for them and
what I should have said was there's 14
part-time members of staff and that on
average they are paid 17 000 pounds per
annum thank you chairman uh thank you
councilor fluka okay moving on I have
apologies from councilor Durham and I
have um councilor Jane Fleming
substituting for councilor Thompson do I
have any other apologies for this
evening
that's terrible there's Farmers
um I um right okay right we'll move on
um now
thank you councilor shauncey I'd also
like to give my apologies for being late
absolutely no problem at all I think the
seven o'clock's made it quite difficult
to get here and I'm actually surprised
everybody's here and it's only just
after seven okay right we'll now move on
to the agenda and we have
um agenda item 14 which is the data
management and insight strategy
um and who's taking this one Cheryl okay
uh Miss Hughes could you do this one for
us please
and so the UK National Data strategy has
set out as a practice
practical use of data and insight this
report and the recommendations are
intended to work towards this best
practice
ethics Partners have been developing the
Essex data decoration in line with the
national strategy which sets that
partnership working and is attached as
appendix Savers reports officers are
recommending that we sign up to this
additionally officers have developed a
modern data management and insight
strategy which is set out at appendix B
of your report it sets out an ambition
to be more data driven and identifies
our specific strengths of weaknesses in
doing so
shown on page 253 of the agenda packet
if members approve this strategy
officers will also develop an internal
action plan against the four priorities
set out in strategy to report through to
the performance governance and audit
committee those four priorities are
championing the use of data and
analytics building data literacy and
capability adopting responsible and
accessible data and delivering change
monitoring progress and measuring tests
thank you
uh thank you Sean I've got some
questions but we will pass it over to
the floor but before we do we've got
three recommendations little one is that
members approved signing up to the Essex
data declaration which is in appendix a
little two that members review and
approve the internal data management and
insight strategy which is appendix B and
little three is that the committee
recommends referral to the performance
governance and audit committee for
action plan review and tracking due to
Links in committee responsibilities and
circulation of the strategy to all
members to promote a data driven
approach and awareness now I have been
told after the last meeting that I've
been informed that you're only allowed
to ask one question so what I would say
is that you need to ask one and then
think very carefully about it and if you
need a supplementary comeback but it
will be discretionary a point of order
chairman I'm sorry that I I I'm sorry
Tim but this this is contrary to what
um the
procedurals or the rules of procedure
says it says that members are allowed to
speak for three minutes on a any agenda
item and I think that begs the question
chairman and I think we had this at
Council where you've got eight or nine
recommendations where we did a council
then for anybody only to be allowed to
speak for three minutes disenfranchises
their Democratic rights so chairman can
you tell me who advised you to say that
thank you he came in an email I can't
remember who told me but I definitely I
couldn't get back to you on that one
because it definitely came in an email
to me I was advised of it
no it doesn't no no I think it was said
to all of us can you can when you find
out can you ask that officer to propose
a motion to council saying you're only
allowed to ask one question yeah thank
you uh Council wagon
yeah thanks chair I think it came um out
and it was directed for a piece of
advice about when emotion is raised
um and it was about the it was a the
rules of procedure but that was about
emotion so this is a debate and a
recommendation within an order paper
which when I went through the
Constitution and checked against that
didn't seem to apply so I think it's
down to the Chairman's you know
discretion if they feel they would add
debate and I would be very disappointed
because I found personally from being in
the chair that when a questions asked if
triggers a thought process that other
members might go I've got a
supplementary question or even maybe a
couple and and you know you've been
subject to that yourself
yes absolutely so I think that that
applies to emotion and it's very clear
and there's reasons for you can talk
about urgent business as well but I
think that that that might you can feel
how the shame has gone down and I think
it will be very remiss to stifle debate
on what are really important
um transparent and Urgent business items
yeah uh councilor siddle uh thank you
madam chairman I I think the uh the
email referred to as not talking for
more than three minutes
um I think we can ask as many questions
as we want within that three minutes and
that members can come back once I think
was the guidance
um I mean I I am pretty lenient in this
committee but we do need to move on so
what I'm saying is if we try and keep it
concise that would be much better for me
as chairman and we might finish before a
ridiculous time at night but a counselor
stamp
um yes thank you chairman at Georgia
stand Madam chair
thank you um I'd actually like to
congratulate you on this last meeting
the one previous to this because I
thought it was very difficult to share
because you've got very strong members
on this committee and we represent our
residents we represent our residents and
I I cannot stand the thought that you're
going to or whoever is trying to stifle
us when we've got important things to
say and also if it's one question you're
going to have and and when I want to
speak because I can't always think as
you know straight away off the top of my
head and I I write loads of notes down
which you'll see tonight if you want to
check but if you're going to try and
limit limiters I think that is really
unfair and undemocratic yeah thank you
but if from the chat it is to move the
meeting on thank you councilor swing
um yes I agree entirely your point about
um conciseness and um avoiding
verbiosity or whatever and prolonging
things but what needs possibility of
coming back on items because
um otherwise it really prevents any sort
of dialogue and reconsideration of uh
one's a view with additional information
which I see as a quite a key point of
these meetings okay right moving on
because we've already done five minutes
so right moving on
um we will now go back to the um
actually the gender item which is
management Insight strategy
um councilor siddle is this related to
the it is good perfect
I I think this report is excellent and
it's really something that yeah will
really uh add benefit to the council in
terms of how we make decisions and how
we measure our performance so the more
we can focus upon this and the more we
can use this sort of strategy I think it
will be absolutely uh brilliant so yeah
I I recommend uh this this thing and
agree with everything that's in it okay
accounts leveling thank you chair I just
wanted to learn some more I was
particularly with this sort of thing I
was worried as to where the data ends up
and is it data that can be sold to other
parties I I see that central government
are Consulting at the moment about data
sharing so for me I'd prefer that this
was brought back at a later date when we
can see the results of that central
government consultation because we do
have to be careful
with these areas I think sharing
residence data
um anyway I listen to everyone else's
thoughts
uh misses
okay so the intention for the data use
in terms of sharing is working with our
partners to identify key areas where we
would um like intervene or work for the
residents of Malden is not to share it
in terms of commercial profit or
um anything like that it's purely for
the purposes of driving services and and
working out how to deliver to our
customers
okay so where would the sharing start
and end who are we sharing from um Tim
would it be as far as the National
Health Service
um
thank you councilor Fluker
it depends on the partnership whether
that working in so um I would see at the
particular Partnerships like one Malden
District might have a particular problem
and then it's looking at what data that
we've got access to that might help with
that but it would be within the binder
Partnerships where we would be sharing
data
okay thank you
um okay councilor Channel
um thank you madam chairman just for
clarity and actually follows on from
something councilor Fleming's just said
about she'd be interested to know
regarding this and especially regarding
residence data I mean does it in any way
affect because we all know well I have
put it on my emails about when we get
information coming into us from
residents and we say we won't share with
third parties
so does it have a influence on that
because in one hand I'm saying that and
then from what I'm reading from this
certain data could be shut I understand
you've just said Partnerships but
actually that could be as seen as third
parties
yeah so it'd never be at the raw data
level that we would share things so
where I'm talking about sharing we'd be
sharing things like insights so for
example our recent Resident survey and
the Insight that we've learned from that
and we can compare with the recent Essex
resident Insight survey and what they've
learned about the residents of Malden
rather than specific individual data
right that's Collective too sorry
manager so so as close terms is just
Collective data it's not name data
because I'm really
I wasn't realizing how extensive the
sharing was going to be
[Music]
opening up our customer data that's not
part of what this work is doing
okay um I'll do do you want to come in
quickly councilor Fleming
thank you
um Cheryl that that information is
available publicly anyway our resident
survey you know
those reports are available
you know our partners reports those type
of reports are available publicly anyway
so I I'm not if you're not going to
share the raw data and you're just going
to share the sort of broad brush reports
that come from that there will public
documents so I don't really see what
words to be achieved here
first
okay Council Swain next yes I can
imagine there's quite a lot of internal
data that that isn't publicly available
um perhaps on something like
homelessness where sharing it in the
aggregate um with other authorities
um could be benefits not as Michelle
says no no information is going to be
identifying individual people but um I
can see that some internal information
will be a benefit if shared with other
bodies
okay and Council Lagan then councilor
Stanton and counselor Channel thank you
chair I'll just um
two things one the quality of the report
is excellent so I'd second that
um and the other point is I totally
agree with councilor Fleming I think if
there's
um stairs and direction from government
I think we'd probably need to defer this
just to be really sure that we've got
everything right because we've got this
oven ready if necessary to come out and
we could the the the the concerns that
are being raised now can be alleviated
with just a couple of tweaks
um and away we go so I really support
what councilor Fleming says
uh thank you um councilor stamp and
thank you madam chair
um sorry to borrow everybody but I've
just done that for afternoon or thingy
course on 12 local government digital
digitalization outcomes with key action
points checklists for councilors and it
actually says but the leadership ensure
your Council has a clear plan strategy
to drive digitalization across the
council ensure your Council has the
culture and enabling environment for
digitalization to thrive it's a massive
document a lot of work was covered and
and my immediate points when I was
reading the report I've put the points
I've put is what does it mean to
Residents cut before the house a
workshop is required for cancers to
actually understand how the data is
going to be collected and used for what
is it for an analysis at this Council to
look at the data they're collecting to
make our services better more robust
more fine-tuned we need to know why
we're going to be collecting this data
um I actually read on two pages on on
page 249 the data declaration working
group asked itself with what a
successful implementation of this
commitment set out Declaration would
look like who was on that group
what is it it's just it's just we're
actually being asked to approve appendix
a but who was on that group is it
members of the council is it a generic
one that's just been produced in Essex
and I'd also like to know Madam chair
um how does it align an appendix book be
supporting policies and strategies how
does that align with everything that
we're actually putting together
um another two questions I know I've had
more than one
um how will the data be protected same
as Council Fleming what happens about um
cyber security the protection of
firewalls
um encryption and what about our cyber
resilience when we've got data collected
we all know and the people I met on this
course were from up and down the country
and you'll be amazed at how many people
have had cyber attacks and they have
actually with some of the information
that has then come in as their cyber
attacks rendered their councils
but inoperational because it's taken out
everything that they need to use so I
actually applaud this coming to council
but I don't think there's enough
information and I certainly won't
support it at this stage I think members
need a lot more training a lot more
understanding of what it means I think
it's a cables word Madam chair but until
you actually I was amazed at how deep
this subject was and if anybody wants to
actually read the book they actually
promote to it is a book called
accelerate and if you start to read
something like that you you might but
understand what they're actually wanting
to to do and what it actually means
thank you madam chair okay and msues
okay sorry for Cheryl
gdpr and all the security compliant with
our data use and obviously part of this
strategy and the action plan associated
with it is making you know is making
people aware and making sure we are gdpr
compliant and that we do use data
properly and store data properly so in
having the strategy in place it
those concerns you know that that's part
of what would be driving it and in terms
of the working group it was an officer
working group and they put this together
and it's being taken through all Essex
authorities in terms of signing up to it
um there was another question sorry
um uh councilor Stan what was the other
question
policies and strategies
um what does it mean to the residents
and members
um why hasn't members had a workshop to
understand the detail and I do think we
need to actually have a little bit more
information about the digitalization
because it will come central government
if you if you look at central government
departments they use a lot of it now
anyway but wherever district council at
the public share and I think we just
need to be cautious don't mind signing
up to something if I know what to sign
up for it and I don't think there's
enough information at all
so the government strategy is what
shaped the ethics strategies and the
molding strategy and it's linked within
the main report so there is a national
strategy and that not I'm not aware that
it's designed to change that's what set
out the best practice that we're trying
to work towards
um in this report
okay uh thank you um councilor fluka
yeah thank you chairman
yeah it's amazing isn't it like a page
and a half a gender item generates so
much conversation
um
you know Kevin I must submit 3.2 it does
concern me slightly about this sharing
of data
um you know my my feeling generally
about these these type of agenda items
um
you know I can remember when I was
chairman and vice chairman strategy and
resources we used to rehearse our
meetings councilor then sis me and
myself with officers so that we could
basically work out all the questions
that were going to be answered and then
put the answers in the report which
meant we used to have very very brief
meetings and they all used to work well
so but really you know the one that I'm
really interested in is and I've said
this before people often go because we
don't have even though we agreed to have
an executive summary at the beginning of
all the gender items we still have to go
to implications and on this one impact
on resources Finance financial data
given approaches enable us to make best
use of The Limited finances and Target
the areas that need it most well
chairman really doesn't speak to whether
or not we're going to spend more or less
or there's going to be a surplus or a
deficit and and I think it would be
useful for these things to be expanded
so members can fully understand what's
going on but German save as regard to
sharing a data and having read the
report it seems to the actual
uh data declaration from page 247
actually gives quite a good insight into
how this is going to be done so
generally speaking you know I would
support these recommendations but I
think that it may have been useful to
have a a member's seminar on this on
teams you know uh and then you'd find
that it would probably fly through this
evening German three minutes yeah misuse
would there be any implications if we
defer this for the next agenda
um just so that other than we wouldn't
obviously be signing up to the Essex
declaration at the same as the same time
as the others
um but otherwise just delay the program
of work yeah and do we know what the
Financial Risk
um is
you know would have been charged to sign
up
you know it's just that we've
um well there would be a delay in us
moving towards best practice and that
partnership working
okay and would it um is it tied into
devolution
or is it Standalone okay thank you
councilor fluka if you briefly come back
briefly I mean the the thing about these
things are for all we know all of the
councils are listed at the bottom of
page 247 May well have debated this and
and had their own concerns
um because at the moment it just says
they've been involved in drafting I mean
I don't know who's I presume misuse has
been involved in the drafting from
Malden
um but have we got any feedback for all
of these other partners because they're
all there all 36 of them
um before we know they might have
changed things we then sign up to it and
they've actually changed something that
we haven't seen I know somebody has to
go first and somebody has to go last but
you know is this a live document is this
out of date I I I really don't
understand it misuse
and we don't necessarily have control of
shape in the document the document is
being designed by the S6 partner officer
group and it's just a case of whether we
sign up to it or not
okay so okay briefly councilor Fleming
quickly and then councilor Channel and
then we'll go to the vote on this one
thank you chair Cheryl do you know how
many have actually signed up then
at this stage I don't know at this
particular moment in time okay Council
Tanner thank you madam chairman
um my question earlier on and this is a
actually an addendum to that or an
addition to it
and the reason I did ask it because
um on page 252 it does refer to the fact
information comes in many forms policy
documents minutes statistics operational
data Case Files personal data and
research papers and then when I read the
document and I'm not saying it's not a
good document misuse I want to make that
clear but my brain was trying to work
out I couldn't see then where that there
was
um disseminate into where how that
applied into why the mention of personal
data Etc and then on 256 the other thing
on page 256 when it's Priority One
I noticed it referred to we will improve
officer and member use of data by
ensuring we have the appropriate tools
for using and sharing it and create key
performance indicators to ensure our
data is being used and the quality is
being improved now to me it's mentioned
members there so I immediately came to
think that is going to be data I'm
processing because I'm a data controller
or whatever data processor controller
that somehow members are also then going
to be have performance measures included
with officers or is it separate
um really we're talking about kpis so
does that mean members will have kpis
appropriated to them in how they handle
the data and the and the quality of it
not trying to be difficult it's just
that I needed to get comprehension of
the document
because it's two separate points
actually uh what we're saying is um we
make it so that members and officers can
access and use data and the appropriate
tools are things like mapping tools
um and uh performance report dashboards
and then that's the second point about
um we as an organization will make sure
that we've got kpis to ensure that we're
using and processing data in a good
quality way so yeah it's it I take what
you're saying that should be two
separate bullet points okay cancel the
flickers briefly before I go to council
meeting
yes yes we did yes
yes
let me see do you remember that so I'm
not sure there's we used to have your
favorites the uh a feed the information
commissioner's office as members and um
yeah then it used to be refunded to us
like if I was such a long time ago I
don't even really remember it yeah um in
fact S6 when I was like S6 I think S6
did it jointly it could cover me for
both I'm trying to remember correctly
but there was we had to pay one time 35
pounds or something that's a a number
coming into my brain and I'm not sure
okay councilor still uh thank you madam
chairman I think yeah we we are now
confusing gdpr with this with this
document gdpr already protects the
sharing of data and personal data that
is is built into legislation the reason
why you don't do Ico anymore is because
alleged legislation changed a couple of
years ago so that's the reason why
um so gdpr came in in 2018 I think it
was so that then changed all of that if
you look at page uh I can't read that uh
two five eight it says that we will
ensure part of this policy this policy
is about creating these things and about
creating these controls and and these
things so it says the right data is
available to write people and only them
using a privacy privacy by Design
approach so we are ensuring by adopting
this policy that we are protecting that
data not really so it is if we if we if
we hold back on this policy it then
holds us back in terms of creating these
things and that's that's what I see in
terms of this document if we sign up to
it
it will enable us to be more effective
in how we use our data and the way that
we control it not less
and I think that's one of the crucial
things
uh thank you um well I have to say I
actually have concerns um about this one
myself
um with with how far the data sharing is
going and I I don't I'm not sure we've
had enough information
um so
um we've got uh agenda we've got a
recommendation it's a lot a little eye a
little two and a little three
um but if anybody wants to propose a
little four that is deferring for
another meeting until members have
looked into it I'm I'm open to that
suggestion as well so members down to
you Kevin I think there was a proposal
on the table
to propose you know to accept those
three and I think we should do that
first and then okay councilor siddle
would you like to put your proposal
again those those story recommendations
to be adopted okay do we have a second
for that I'll second it oh it counts the
challenge second is it okay members if
choose this by a sentence I think with
that with that Amendment right as you
said about the two bullet points
well no we're just voting on them as
they stand
yeah yeah okay right members uh show of
hands please all those in favor
one two three four five all those
against
one two three four do we have any
abstentions
no well that's Carrie then looks like
we're accepting those as they are on the
order paper right okay well they're
members
um moving forward to a gender item 15.
um new fee for the collection of waste
upholstered domestic seating containing
persistent organic pollutants
um and who have we got for this one got
oh Mr Holmes for this one
thank you German apologies for the
tongue twisting uh the title of this
report but you'll see that there is a
new fee in charge produced uh I've been
proposed for the separate collection of
waste upholstered domestic seating or
what concerning persistent organic
pollutants or pops you will see that the
legislation has changed from the
environment agency with compliance
required from beginning of January 2023
but there has been an extension of that
deadline to August 2023.
um section
316 of the report and gives members an
indication of the type of materials that
would include the pops and you'll see
that in a range of sofas
upholstery kitchen dining room furniture
pretty much and what you find in most
households
um obviously there is implications to
our existing waste and recycling
Contracting that we do offer bulky waste
collections so officers have
investigated how we might be able to
comply with the legislation to collect
this material and store it separately
and we've been working with our our
refuse contractor Sue is to to look at a
number of options in your will see that
option two are under three two four of
the report in terms of how we might be
able to collect that separately and
manage it has been identified that would
result in an additional charge one-off
charge for a 14 pounds 50 on top of the
existing bulky waste collection and that
will allow for the material to be
collected and stored separately in
accordance with the regulations we are
very conscious that we don't want to
create a situation where we might
accidentally increase any fly chipping
and people disposing of materials
inappropriately so we want to re-offer
the service and we have just
reintroduced that service for residents
and you'll see that's been done for the
last two months of this financial year
to allow those types of materials to be
collected and we would recommend that
the additional charges included in the
fees and charges uh going forward for 23
24. thank you for good questions we've
got two recommendations little one
members approved an additional fee of 14
pounds 50 is the list of fees and
charges for 23.24 for mixed bulky waste
requests containing Woods to ensure that
collection costs are covered for their
separate collection as per guidance
provided by the environment agency and
little two that members note the new fee
will be introduced for the last two
months of 22-23 financial year predicted
income would fall within limits set
under delegation to ensure the surfaces
can be offered to the public as soon as
possible okay councilor Swain
yes thank you um I mean with large items
they may be a residents may want them
just collected as an individual item
would one just charge the 14.50 for that
rather than the double seems unjustified
chance to double fee and the other thing
I know with some of these smaller ones
um uh the inclination would be to take
them to the tip what happens in that
situation
this time thank you uh so no this would
be a charge on top of because there is a
cost of the truck going out and and
collecting the actual item itself
um but because it has to be also stored
in a separate way you know it's
effectively an average cost
um yeah what would it cost to actually
process per collection so I thought it
would be a charge on top of
um what happens if you take it to the
recycling center that can be taken there
so residents can actually do it and the
County Council will dispose of it
appropriately a store it and dispose it
appropriately
okay councilor Channel and then Council
Legend oh thank you uh Mr Holmes just
used the word um collection which I
understand but let's say you've got four
of these um kitchen chairs I think they
come into the equation which are your
waste upholstered domestic seating
containing persistent organic pollutants
um would they be treated let's say
you've got four chairs or six chairs is
that deemed as one collection costing 14
pounds or is it every individual item in
that collection or will it attribute the
14 pound just to get the clarity on that
per collection per collection
okay Council Legend
thank you chair it's difficult at least
it's not the we act when that came in
and waste electrical equipment yeah they
love acronyms it's it you have to look
at these two ways one any burden of
increased cost of residences is a burden
and we don't really have any choice if
you step away from it for a fraction and
you think it's it's put on the authority
by the government
these things are really nasty so when
they you know if they went in the ground
they are horrible things so having them
taken out of the degenerate waste stream
and actually treated so that these
poisons aren't in the ground makes
absolute total sense and as Mr Holmes
has said to from from experience of
running these types of services in
therefore sending a truck out and you
think about how big our district is you
know if you'll send it down to the Genji
for 14 pounds it's probably cheaper to
do that than what it is to run it in the
petrol and take it to your tip so as
much as I really don't like the
additional charge I I don't see any
other way of doing it
um and and support it and thank the
officer again and um for a really
concise and clear report that says look
this is what what this is the way that
we need to think so thank you absolutely
the M councilor fluka
um
because if you take an average public
connection fear say 50 pounds out there
I'll take the minimum fees we had about
250 based on saying average 100 per
month that's five thousand pounds I
can't see I believe even at the moment
how serious can provide two operatives
pass the Lord ask a few
presumably taking somewhere to be sort
of time exposed for five thousand pounds
so I thought maybe I've misunderstood
this and then we go to the implications
another movement four it says Service
providing should
be self-finance
so again was asked to support the
necessary additional charge I mean now
this goes back to my favorites question
I hope accountancy and we should be
you know I'd like to think
perhaps another episode delivery can
move us into our comfort zone and
explain them what he means if I should
and if it means that it isn't
thank you chairman so the figure that
has been calculated has been done with
sewers and I wouldn't be expecting to
pay any more than that amount per
collection so effectively it's a plusage
on top of the normal bulky waste
collection which should cover any
additional costs for either a separate
vehicle collection and the storage and
then the safe disposal of that material
come back Kevin I mean that begs the
question I mean it would you know
obviously if there's no default fault
payment to the council that's fine
there's no reason why we shouldn't go
this but I just find it I just find it
extraordinary having dealt with Suez
over the years
um that you know they're managing to put
two two operatives to lower the fuel the
cost of running the truck for five
thousand pound a month but
um yeah I think that um just perhaps if
you you'd um worded
but before we come into the business of
the meeting there are a few housekeeping
wow that's I said the ghoster ghost of
Maddie Thompson
Thompson that wasn't me but not not only
have I uh been a ventriloquist I've
changed my voice I'm impressed yeah I'm
right sorry be brief please yeah yeah of
course but well I've got my timer
running chairman and even around Council
Thomas I'm only at two minutes 40
seconds
um but again you know if that just that
paragraph Mr Holmes have that been
expanding out slightly I would have
saved you three minutes and 18 seconds
thank you
Mr Holmes no did you check
okay thank you right members um there's
no other questions we'll go to the vote
uh with the recommendations little one
and little two
um can we agree with this by a cent
please all those in favor
yeah lovely thank you okay moving on to
agenda item 16 which is statement of
consultation the local development plan
review issues and options document on
pages 265 to 388 with uh Ms Anne altoft
Shoreland oh who's there chairman before
you start yeah yes thank you madam
chairman yes please Madam chairman Mar
declare an interest in that regarding
the consultation responses which I
believe are online I'm sure
um
listen out of shouldn't will confirm
that because the link goes to the
website I just want to declare Madam
chairman that a friend many
acquaintances and my husband actually
did respond to the consultation so I'll
just declare that it's their views
um and so I just thought I'd put that on
record but I don't think it stops me
from involvement in this item no I don't
think so and I think we're all in the
same boat
um with friends um commenting okay uh
Miss Charlotte
yeah good evening members so this item
is the statement of consultation from
issues and options term consultation the
consultation ran from 17th of January to
the 1st of April last year and it's part
of the methodology of the local
development um review of the development
Fair review so we have 419 responders
made up of various
organizations of people members of the
public Parish councils businesses
statutory Consultants developers agents
and various groups so in the main there
was support for the vision and
objectives of the ldp review lots of
comments about infrastructure which is
not surprising really which is also a
reflection of all the comments that come
back from members that we've been having
for the last two years
strong strong objections to matters like
building a higher densities but you know
we've got plenty of room we don't
actually have to do that we don't want
we choose not to
support for climate change which is
which affirms the priority the council
has given that in its uh in its business
plan A
um with regard to infrastructure the
majority of this respondents thought
growth should be located where there was
access to bus and transport links and
that development needed to be connected
by uh to the nearest settlement by
pavement which is which is a good good
support
there was support for a major project
policy very various comments but I think
the one thing that we picked up
throughout the whole
response was that all the comments about
infrastructure and they were scattered
throughout the whole of the consultation
nearly every respondent mentioned it and
you know I don't I don't think we could
count them because there were so many of
those types of comments
and I think that just is a reflection of
how important that is to the council and
how important it is when we continue
planning in the future
so the next steps is we need to publish
this statement it's part of the process
of the ldp reviewed and what we do is we
will then as we work through each of the
policies in the next steps that we go
through will take out parts of this
concept
and we'll use them to help inform our
discussions and decision makings so just
as for it so for example when we come to
discuss
yourself built policy we'll take out the
relevant comment an outcome part of our
debate and discussion when we get
together to talk about that and and work
it out
so the recommendations that we accept
this
statement of consultation okay members
Council step
Madam chair I reserve the right to come
back when the debate starts if that's
okay with you I'm actually confused
about what we're actually actually going
to approve tonight are we going to
approve that we acknowledge that we've
had all these responses but we're doing
nothing or what is it just for noting
because my understanding is that how
at a later date some of the responses
may go to make a ldp or a some
strategies but we haven't agreed
anything yet so are we just agreeing the
summary of the responses that the
officers put together thank you Miss out
of Charlotte
yes what we're doing is we're agreeing
that we've got consultation responses
and that we're publishing them that's
what we're doing tonight we don't we
don't we don't go to use them in in any
work until we get into the process of
the ldp review they're going to help
shape the policies
okay Council thank you I welcome back
after this so we're not actually
agreeing and tying ourselves down to
anything only the information
thank you
okay counselor Logan
thank you chair I I see that as what I
understand under the Town and Country
planning local England regulations 2012.
it is it says it's basiness statutory
obligation that we have to fulfill
so under Point eighteen one this is a
local Authority must notify the bodies
specified a paragraph two of the local
plan the local planning Authority
proposed to prepare and invite each of
them to make representatives to local
planning Authority about a local plan
we've got subject ought to contain so
that's really what we've done we've gone
out and we've said look we're doing a
review this is a part of the statutory
process that we have to do and these is
the response so it's it's a data
collection exercise where we've got all
of these stairs from people in in the
district our residents so that it can
then park it then it can come to members
and members can look through those and
distillate what is the really important
aspects are I.E your infrastructure
obviously we could have done that um
sitting at home so am I 100 clear that
that is what we've done and we've got
490 respondents that's quite low
um but but here's what it is and one
other point in there I think it said in
the report that there was enough to
excuse me um
I've made a few mistakes today I don't
want to make another one so
um
it says that there was things 28 000
responses and when I looked at one of
the questions I mean there's some really
decent responses and some you know I
talked about going down a rabbit hole
for gold there's a lot of
um in a table there's a lot of first
names oh sorry twenty three thousand
four hundred responses but there's a lot
of names last name organization and the
information is blank is that 28 000 is
that is that just the numbers of speech
numbers of cells on the spreadsheet or
is that the actual number of cells that
were filled in with feedback that came
back to us so there's two sides there
one just confirming that it would that
section 18 is just a statutory tick in
the Box we've done that and now we've
got this data and two was it twenty
three thousand four hundred actual
written responses or is it twenty three
thousand four hundred cells in the
spreadsheet
thank you
miss out of Charlotte
I think it was 20.
it was 23 000 sales on the excels
spreadsheet because we just couldn't
count
that we just couldn't count all of the
individual responses it just was you
know it was just too much really to be
honest it didn't didn't really achieve
anything so yeah so I'll just come back
so it will we count the actual responses
that came back because that that's is is
the is the the graphs that are included
in the report just for these responses
they obviously have to be because you
can't put nothing in about nothing can
ya
question in in the response we do the
synopsis at the end in the report that
says you know question one and then
you've got the bar the pie charts
obviously there's nothing where somebody
hasn't given you any information you
haven't put anything in there
if you haven't included that as part of
the question
yes yeah I've got the uh
yeah
I think Council said it was really got
what he's picking up while I'm traveling
so I'll pass it to councilor zero
[Laughter]
uh yeah so uh we had all those numerous
questions and one of the things I think
in terms of this consultation was is we
have to learn about this consultation is
the questionnaire was far too complex
and there were too many questions and it
turned people off
um so one of the things we learned from
this the consultation is good the data
that we've got is good but because there
were so many questions that's why there
are blanks and and why people didn't
feel those those particular things in
maybe they didn't feel it was relevant
so when we consult in the future we have
to ensure that whatever we consult on is
user friendly and is something that
people people can use uh in terms of
this I think it sets us in a good
position now to move the the local plan
review forward
um and yeah we can use this as a basis
ensuring that we take into account
what residents say in terms of any
options that we narrow down which is
where we're going next
okay cats thank you so it's the Swain
then Council of China then councilor
fluka
yes thank you um
yeah I can quite see that we need to
publish the results of the consultation
and um as uh
Shoreland says that that can be helpful
in um moving forward various policies
um but
there's one respondent that we have
responded to in this document namely the
County Council
um so
um
my question is really whether we should
publish the county council's responses
but not not the no we should publish
their responses but we shouldn't publish
our responses to the County Council in
other words all the red bits in the um
in the document yeah I think what
counselor is asking are we publishing
our comments to assist counter Council
are they being omitted the bits they're
in writing red writing where it says
council's response
yeah but we were intending to publish
our response but with regard to the
county they you know they've made
comments but we have
um duty to cooperate meetings with them
so they're
they're their response to our policy
creation will be iterative so as we move
forward we're going to have to work work
with them much more closely and when an
organization like the county Banks
comments on something like issues and
options it's always very Broad and it
doesn't really have annoyances of what
you would actually discuss on duty to
cooperate meetings to be fun
okay
chair seems to me that um we would have
to take into account what the County
Council say
um and we're putting that out there in
public and effectively
um uh which we say hamstringing
ourselves to some extent
um I I would think it's not a good idea
to publish those replies because as has
been said the areas will be covered or
those points will be covered in the duty
to cooperate and the dialogue continuing
dialogue with um the easy easy and other
partners
yeah so I think what council is asking
is would publish them produce any future
changes to policies or responses in
light of the comments to the Essex
County Council responses
no no no we we have the right to
um
we have the right to introduce our
policies as we wish and they they have
the right to comment as they wish then
the comments they've made may not be the
final comments that they have because
we've got to put lots of work on the
policies so where they've talked about I
don't know I'm trying to think what they
talk about let's talk about highways so
when they talked about their views on
the hot the highway in that comment
those views may change
when we do our transport modeling
so it's almost like a snapshot in time
that they've given us a view on
um I mean we can take our responses out
and just do a generic one at the end
saying thank you for your comments we'll
take them under advisement and we'll
we'll talk to you in our duty to
cooperate meetings it doesn't really
matter yeah okay so I think members have
some concerns on it
um being a bit premature
um but I'll put that to vote before we
make the other decisions okay I've got
cancer Chana and then Council Lagan and
then we'll go to the vote uh thank you
all councilor fluka
um thank you madam chairman I think the
reason councilor stamp may have asked
about how this would be used because 4.3
does say the council use the statement
of consultation and consultation
responses and the continuing work of the
ldp review as it moves towards the next
regulation 18 regulation 18 stage of
preferred option so obviously that
implies but it's more than implies it
will indicate some of those consultation
response it will help her shape not only
policy but may be a preferred option but
I'd can the officer say that it's not it
the in that's not exclusive it's not
just those consultation responses
regarding Essex County Council then what
I would say if we're removing the
responses to their representation I
believe on the website and to correct me
if I'm wrong because the link in this
document mod.gov appears to take me to
the website of our Authority and I think
all the consultation responses are on
there are they not with the responses of
officers and correct me if I'm I'm wrong
on that Council siddle's quite correct
in terms of I actually think there may
have been more people would have
responded I'm aware people did become
frustrated in terms of actually when um
when they were filling in they might try
and keep going back to documents they
were background documents going in when
they then came back to where they'd
filled in a question disappeared and um
and also some people I'm aware did
actually complete the 4 form whether
they are answered or they actually rang
the offices where it did say an officer
would assist so I think there are issues
here to be learned on the consultation
in terms of making sure when you're
going into it you don't find things
disappearing
um just because you go back because some
of the background documents I was
informed were very lengthy and actually
require a bit of time to read and you
might have wanted to tweak your response
um having you know read the document
more than once so I just make those
points but I think we need to be clear
of what the use is and that's I think
what council stamps point was trying to
get clarification on clearly and to me
it does indicate it they will be used
and in fact will influence both policy
and possibly the preferred option
regulation 18. thanks
and I think a question that I'm I'm
seeing coming out of that is have I
already been published to the public
yeah of course yeah but yeah do they go
to a link on the website though a
separate link it's not just on the
agenda
well on mob.gov when you go into mod
that the link that's in the report it
says these responses are able to view in
the mod.gov library on the council's
website I clicked on
and there we go council's website
document public consultation responses
so I took it to be that is in the public
domain
it's on there
sorry and then when you click on the
PDFs questions one to seven you've got a
raft of all the names
views and then then the council's
responses hence why I'm saying why if we
take we're now going to take off Essex
County the response to Essex County
Council we've got a host of members of
the public here where it's already out
there okay so that's why I'm saying am I
correct yes you are correct and what
I've just been told by Mr Holmes is
although they've been published it's
down to us to approve them which still
seems the wrong way around I I presume
they were just in the agenda for tonight
um right okay
um we've got
um cancer Lagan Council Fluker and
councilor stamp thank you I'll be quite
sure
um yeah I'm just a bit really by what's
just been spoken there I think
if if you'd indulge me basically on
section one the purpose of the report I
think where it says in 1.1 the purpose
of this report for the committee is
consider the statement of consultation
in regards to regulation 18 which we've
already talked about issues and options
documents which was subject to public
consultation between the 17th of January
2022 and 14th of March 2022. the
decision this report recommends will
support the delivery of a lawful and
sound modern District development plan
review the statement of consultation is
attached Independence one what worries
me a fraction is the decision this
report recommends there's no decision
that the report recommends so what I'd
recommend is on recommendation to the
council is that we just changed the
recommendation because it hasn't been
um boatenged yet that the statement of
consultation with the Northern District
council's local development plan
regulation issues and options document
be noted rather than approved because
it's not a decision-making document yeah
yeah it's just an information document
we've collected this data with looking
at it we're going to take it to the next
stage because then we have to go through
working groups and members to be able to
decide what the next stage is and
officers will make sure the regulations
are all ticked okay
I mean um how does this affect
um governance and the regulations does
it does it be approved and would it
affect the outcome if it was just noted
before it went to council how does that
affect us would it put us in Jeopardy in
any way
oh my God
it was at risk
of the council will approach
I thought that's what you were saying
what were you actually saying
this report
is to set to satisfy them the report is
to satisfy section 18 of the regulations
which I've got it here is clear doesn't
say it has to be has to be um approved
and then once we go to council we say
that is noted so we've done that piece
of regulatory work we've got the data
and when we next move into the next
stage when we start to look at shaping
what the ldp actually wants and what we
want to be able to put in there we've
got this plethora of golden
opportunities and information that
residents have given us for us to be
able to look at
yeah that's right so I think the simple
question is does it need to be approved
and what what risks would there be or
what outcome will be if we just noted
the report
as long as it's been through the process
you've looked at it we can publish it
it's part of the process we're going to
use those as we move through the uh the
rest of the work I think we'll be
completely fine okay we're talking about
approving it for publication
it's already published that's the whole
thing that's what that's what we're
asking it's already been published
that's the whole thing about counselor
we're asking is why are we having to
approve it when it's already published
that's what it's boiling down to and
councilor fluka yeah thank you Jim I'm
you know I'm just concerned about what
Miss shawland said in as far as the fact
that to quote her I think it will be
okay this is a local development plan
you know I've sat through two public
inquiries I think the councilor Chen has
probably been 33 uh and these are the
sort of things that come back to haunt
us
um and Ben Iman this um this meeting
tonight will be available for people to
listen to and and you know previously
we've said we could have done better
with regards to this report but you know
the officers are tagged Ted hogtied
because if you look on page 266 at the
top
um
so I hate you to miss what I say
um you know if you look at page 266 on
the top you know unfortunately officers
had to use emergency powers and I
believe that strategy and resources for
all the reasons that were said tonight
weren't particularly happy and wanted
the opportunity to pursue this further
at Council but clearly didn't get that
opportunity and I think with hindsight
it would have been good if we'd had a
working group around about that time
where we could have thrashed out the
questions in this but going back to
Essex County Council I'm really really
concerned about what's been said because
if one reads the response to the mancaps
application in Burnham Essex County
Council have basically said no more
housing until you build a secondary
school now you can read that response
it's Crystal Clear just type in mancaps
under the search engine you'll go there
and it's quite damning and they also say
quite clearly that they didn't support
any of the seven options that we sent
out it's a really really interesting
report
um and I was going to email Michelle and
say that I think it's a matter of
urgency it should be considered with the
very very lease the the policy or the
ldp review group okay well if I might
come in
um because I think I'm getting a bit
confused as to what what are members
concerns if you help me out to ask
Michelle as well what are members
concerns with the proving this document
in in simple terms but I don't know if
anybody can put them in really easy
bullet points Gemini and I know I've got
all the individual items like
um the problems this is County Council
saying no more housing until a secondary
school is built
you know at the end of the day all we're
doing is approving something that we've
just pulled together the information so
I think councilor leggings got hit a
proposal on the table but chairman if
that fails then I would propose that we
agree the recommendation okay okay thank
you I'll quickly go to councilor Stanton
and counselor Chana and then we'll
listen to the recommendation before we
go to the vote okay mine's only just to
to support what council China said about
the consultation I know it's going over
old ground but um on that digital course
I actually gave that example exactly
that example and they they actually did
say that that really shouldn't have
happened about the 60 Questions and that
there was no save button and all this
sort of thing they they actually felt
that we should have done better I think
is the polite way of saying it Madam
chair okay counselor Channel
um I I'm just a bit concerned or
cautious about just saying to note this
because 4.3 does say that it will be
used and I think we're noting if you
just note that doesn't give a clear
indication to people that may have
answered that consultation that their
their information or what they shared
their thoughts and the answers the
council gave will be used so that does
concern me if we just do a noting
process under the approval I'm not sure
that totally spells it out either if I'm
honest
um and to me if we're going to use it we
should make that clear in perhaps
anything we're recommending to council
uh Michelin soft do you have any
comments on what councilor Channel said
[Music]
let's go through tonight
yeah well I think what I'll do
counseling before I take your
um proposal I think well I'll take it to
the vote as it stands and if that fails
then we can hear your proposal
afterwards
just quickly a real quick one so if we
do approve this do we are actually
improving for page 266 all of four so
that includes the revised draft
settlement hierarchy pattern and we're
proving all those at the contest
contents of this report because I
certainly don't approve that we've not
just we've not actually said about
discussing the hierarchy pattern so
that's where my concern is that's where
the Madam chair sorry for talking over
but that's where you asked for the list
of concern it's four and four point one
the issues and options consultation
documents set out the following yeah so
where it says it says revised draft
settlement hierarchy pattern so the way
that this reads whatever's in here we
agree to it yeah so whatever's put in
there we agree to it
that's the point I was trying to make
you know it says we agreed whatever is
in here that's the vision for the
District of 2043.
where it should be a document to inform
I think we've done the piece of work I
mean I don't want to keep us you know
talking to sales around we've done the
piece of work we've got the data to be
able to inform the next stage of the
review
I'm worried that and we've come up with
burnt fingers before where we've agreed
something thinking it's one thing and
it's not it turns out to be another and
this is such a a contentious and
delicate issue I'd hate to sort of tie
us down to something you know counselor
chat well I think that's why we need to
be clear what it should be because
there's a whole things and counselors
stamps just highlighted revised draft
settlement hierarchy pattern
and well that's something to say if we
take it to the vote and see if it's
accepted or not and then if somebody
wants to put an amendment forward if
it's not accepted yes and you're also
looking at
indexed appendix on which is the
consultation
do you know I I think I I think with
this I think it says uh it's only
appendix one
um I I think the more we debased this
the more confused it's got
um I think what we'll do we will take it
to the recommendation now which to the
council that the statement of
consultation disorder sorry I hate using
that I'm terribly sorry but I think my
proposal was before the recommendation
was second in so if someone sectors my
recommendation okay well have you
proposal and I I thought we did the main
vote first but what is your proposal
that means he's changing the report is
going to talk about it
okay Council
yeah I've got a question for Mrs art of
shortland uh in terms of in terms of the
summary of key issues and in terms of
the document that's just been stated
about the settlement hierarchy pattern
can you confirm that those items were
agreed before it went out to
consultation because that's my
understanding is they they were agreed
at that point before the consultation
document went out
foreign
so people have commented on that list of
items
now we're into approving or noting their
comments and then we'll take that piece
of work and later on in the process at
some point you'll get to redo and
re-talk about that list of items okay
and then so it's really easy it's just
like um
in order to form the policies and the
work that we're going to do later on in
the process so you haven't you haven't
agreed anything from the ldp yet
Madam chair why don't we yeah if I might
come back I mean why then was it in the
report in general that was received if
we ended up proving it tonight I know
it's I know it specifically relates to a
gen to appendix one and maybe it's uh
confused the meeting because it's it's
all in there
I think I think it's just a it's just a
recap of what was in what was in the um
instead of going over the whole of the
consultation I think it's just a very
broad recap for members to know what the
consultation was actually about
okay thank you um cancer siddle
uh thank you madam chairman I think the
issue arise around 1.1 and the last
paragraph or the less I could love for
us and if that was to change too uh
that this report's recommendations will
support the delivery of a lawful and
sound molten District local plan review
and we take out the first bit the
decision
and then it says this reports
recommendations will support the
delivery of a lawful and sound
modernistic local plan review
then that makes sense in terms of what
we're deciding tonight or agreeing
tonight yeah I
mean the report's a bit muddled um
councilor lager what was your proposal I
agree with councilor Sid I think maybe
something like that but maybe just sit
in simplistic terms is to say that this
is to inform future
um decision making and also maybe some
maybe on point four
yeah which is the one for me it's 4.1
where it says the issues and options
consultation documents set out the
following so these are not the options
and consultation document
um included analysis of the following
and then you'll tell us they're the
bullet points because what you're saying
is this is what was here and then the
data that we got was back in appendix
one now that you can't make you can't
approve you can't approve that data you
can approve the report but you can't
approve that data because that data is
just there to inform decision making
processes further down the line so how
can you improve someone when someone
says I I do you agree with the spatial
picture of the district
um 24 said no how can I prove that all
right but so are you putting forward
proposal that we note the report prior
to it going to full Council for debate I
think they're probably the easiest way
would be that Madam chair okay do I have
a seconder for the proposal by Council
again Council stamp okay members um can
you give me a show of hands for a cent
if you approve the sorry let's go to the
Tower
is that the report is because
it's one in respect if that's the
statement of consultation because that
praise so we're saying we're noticing a
statement of consultation yeah I think
yeah that's what counselor said he wants
to note the statement of consultation
prior to it going to
um full Council because there are some
concerns over the data and implications
included
is that something our members okay right
all those in favor of the proposal of
council Lagan
one two three four five six all those
against
one
okay that's carried then so the motion
by Council Lagann to note the report
prior to it going to full Council
um and I suspect there will be some
questions on what is included in in
particularly into the items that are
mentioned outside of appendix one and it
might be that that's reviewed before it
goes to full council is that okay Miss
ult
yeah that's fine yeah I think I think
having the the other information on
there has kind of confused the issue for
members um I think it had just been
appendix one stopped appendix one I
think that would have been really easy
to approve
um but okay thank you for that
um thank you very much for your report
thank you members okay right agenda item
17 the South Essex parking partnership
operational Reserve parking project
proposals Pages 389 390 and that's over
to the screen
thank you chairman um as members are
aware we are part of the southeast
parking partnership
and we were notified towards the end of
last year that there was a
official name is operational Reserve but
for any other purpose it's a surplus
um in the monies that are available
um through the parking partnership
under the agreement we have
um that Surplus can be redistributed
back to the local authorities that are
part of that partnership which is indeed
what was agreed and the council had been
made aware that there is now 186 000
pounds that is available for us to cool
down for projects that the projects need
to be related
um to essentially car parking activity
so the legislation sets out the
provisions which is in the report
um what we're asking for tonight members
is approval to pull down on that reserve
for three specific projects
and the projects are in the report and
they in in summary they is a project
which is aiming to bring forward to
members a car park charging strategy
so that will enable us to ensure we have
a consistent and fair policy going
forward with our car park charges enable
us to look to make sure that we are
applying those principles fairly
uh the second and and as part of that
project there will be a task and finish
group with members and so members will
be involved in the in that uh proposal
and that will help inform a review of
our car parking charges
um this year ready for next year
um the second proposal is a project
which is looking at some additional car
parking and so this is for a feasibility
study that will look at a whole range of
feasibility options
um so that is the second project members
and the third project is to fund the
resurfacing of our of of one of our car
parks and which is a white horse and
then some significant repairs to the
second uh car park which is in butt Lane
so members that report is before you
tonight
um and we're just asking for you to
consider those those options members
thank you
okay
um councilor Fleming let me just go to
the um before we start discussing there
is a recommendation and the
recommendations that the three projects
detailed at section 3.7 below are
supported an application is submitted to
the South Essex parking partnership to
utilize the operational Reserve to fund
these projects all of which fall within
section 55 of the road traffic at
1984. okay councilor Fleming
thank you chair
um I'll be frank I was disappointed when
I read this report I'm really
disappointed because
for starters at 1.2
that statement in 1.2 is factually
incorrect the monies do not have to be
used for parking
um I know in fact I sat on this app that
approved rochford's
proposals which they have funded the
highways Rangers for a year they funded
two other schemes they funded the
purchase of air quality
monitoring equipment so to say that we
have to use this money for car parking
just it just is not correct
I just would like that to clarify thank
you
okay uh Mr Porsches
um screen
I think yes um we aren't saying it is it
has to be spent on car parking it's car
parking related issues and highways
related issues which are fall under
Section 55 of the Road Traffic Act
if I can come back it doesn't have to be
related to car parking
it doesn't have to be I and I know that
because I sat on the set that voted
through rochford's proposals I was also
disappointed at the lack of member
engagement this was just dished up to us
um
I mean I understood that there would be
a car parking working group to discuss
this operational Reserve you know prior
to that I just I just think this has
been handled very badly thank you
scream
chairman this is the second time that we
have had this Surplus that is available
to us
um previously it was a couple of years
ago and the process that we followed
this evening is exactly the same process
as we have followed previously the
the reserve when it when it was made
available and I do have a copy of the
minutes of the set meeting was this this
matter was referred back to the lead
offices of the district council to come
forward with proposals back to the set
joint committee
does that answer a question councilor
Fleming
still would just like Miss green you
know it doesn't have to be spent on car
parking the monies do not have to be
spent on car parking so 1.2 is factually
incorrect
um Madam chairman that is an excerpt
from the road traffic Act
okay
yeah actually members I do know that um
we had some issues raised with something
that that would be brought up by
um councilor Mays who I've allowed to
speak at this meeting in this not here
and sorry no not a member of this
committee I'm sorry because amazing he
disappeared you have the invisible um
person but um but no I I think um we
have got some governance issues and
unfortunately the 151 officer couldn't
be here to answer those
um issues and it is one option to defer
this so we can get these cleared up
before we come to a decision on it
um because personally as chairman I
don't want to come to the wrong decision
and I don't want to do something that
isn't fully accepted by the section 151
officer
um so
um I I'm I'm happy to take the debate
but then we can decide offers would
prefer to defer it or not uh Mr POTUS
you might be able to assist us with the
governance issue
yes uh the um
those are the
that that is what is stated in uh number
1.2
they're all or part of the cost of the
provision are made to inspire the local
authority of the parking accommodation
the vehicles otherwise down on highways
roads
and whether in the open or Undercover
so as far as we're aware that meets
there
can we apply a broad broader Spectrum
spectrum and still meet the requirements
I think that's what members are asking
if I'm reading the room
but we would need to look into
okay thank you um right I've got quite a
lot of questions um Mr sorry councilor
Swain then councilor stamp then
cancer siddle and councilor fluka let me
just thank you I think there's a verb
missing because presumably it should say
may be used for these purposes
um but there isn't a verb there
um now this is built up from pcns this
is a matter of information
um are we is our fund
um a shared out part of pcn's collected
across the whole Sepp area or just
Surplus from
pcns in Malden
um that's it for information but um as
far as I can tell
um
the there are many things that um uh the
finance could be used for
um some of which
um should we say
uh really for the scpp to take up
um and others which for the district
council to be able to use and coming
back to this question of well what
happened or didn't happen last time on
governance and the non-meeting of the
parking
task force
um I think members need to see the whole
range of possibilities of what these
funds could be used for
um to enable a more informed choice of
how how we would like to see the money
spent
foreign
if I just go back to the previous
um uh payment that was made to the
district council so the process is has
grown a set it came back to a committee
for a final decision
um so the car parking task and finish
working group has traditionally had a
focus on fees and charges
um rather than Capital Works
um of the council so you could argue
that the expenditure here could be
either for Capital works now the
previous was actually funded our Pion
display equipment um in exactly the same
situation the council was able to use
set money to fund the replacement of
equipment and this committee this world
and this committee made that decision
which obviously then released the
capital of the council back into General
use which could be used for other
projects so that's the process and
that's exactly the same process which we
followed now we've got a number of
identified projects which a council is
looking at we put those forward for
funding um this evening and members have
been asked to support those those
projects so I just wanted to say we
haven't gone away from what happened
before this is the process we have
followed in the past
okay thank you um councilor stamp
thank you I'm going to be brief because
cancer Swain actually agree with him
which is very rare nowadays as well but
uh totally um totally agree um I do
think we could do with a little a few
more options and I do note that it
doesn't have to be spent immediately so
there's no pressure on it
um I think yeah car Parks do need some
work but I also can name some car parks
in Burnham on Crouch especially the
doctor's surgery which is an absolute
Nightmare and to say it's outside the
health health practitioners
um it's a disgrace and I was always told
by Mr Holmes and I think he's going to
rule the day he told me
um when we walk around there Mr Holmes
you actually agreed at what state it's
in but yet again I see that it's all
mold and Centric again with any funding
that's going to Malden and doesn't seem
to go outside and I'm sure cancer fluke
is actually going to turn around and say
he's got the same so I actually don't
support these recommendations I think it
should come back and I think some
Alternatives should be put forward thank
you madam chair okay councilor siddle
next
it does not have to be spent on car
parking it can be spent on environmental
projects it can be spent on a variety of
different things so that is not true and
we've had that information from the
person accept that it can be spent on on
different things the thing about the
first item the car park service so it's
that's already been budgeted for out of
council expenditure so I can understand
I know we're under Financial pressures
but we've got this money let's be
creative about how we use it and the way
that we use it I'm I I know what you did
before which is which is fine but it
doesn't mean we have to do the same
process again and that that's I think
the month the frustration is members do
not feel that we've been consulted and
this has been foisted on us without that
consultation so we do need to have a
task a consultation on this I understand
the lead officer is the one that's going
to make the decision but that doesn't
mean that they don't come and consult
with members about the decision so the
lead officer will go back and so this is
how we want to spend it but surely with
this summer money it should be down to
members to say this is how we want it
spend or this is how we'd like it but so
I I would I'm putting forward a
recommendation that this is deferred and
that from this committee and the
representative from sep is on that
working group that we have a working
group from this committee to work out
including the set rep how this money is
spent
accepted
I agree
uh yeah before we focus on can I just
kind of cancel the fluke my only concern
is
um
whether this should be a council wide
consultation if we're talking about
spending different money in different
Wards but councilor fluka chairman look
look we know that these projects are in
the in the budget my first question
would be the the 28 000 the 7200
um
please tell me that we're not going to
take on additional staff and Consultants
to do that work because the additional
cut
the additional car park well we've been
through that before and the delivery
deliverability of a car parking charging
strategy
I think the deliverability of a charging
strategy I'd like to think that we could
do that in-house we've been dealing with
car parking and charging now for donkeys
years but what there's a couple of
things that concern me about this I mean
councilor siddle makes a good good point
that these these figures are covered off
in in the budget
but
knowing how this has worked in the past
my my advice to members would be would
be to to agree these recommendations
but on the understanding that the 172
700 pounds is actually ring fenced
because we won't be we were going to
spend this money anyway out of our own
for we we have to do the work in butt
Lane and white horse otherwise we won't
get any car parking income but if we if
we go ahead and get the money from if we
go ahead and get the money from sep yeah
um at least we've secured our money we
could find we could find that if we
don't get it quickly we might not get it
it's then under no application we've got
to put I mean Cancer Chan is nodding and
I think we were put under pressure once
before and we lost the money so what I'm
saying is take the money take the money
but on the assumption that the 172 000
pounds that we've already allocated is
now ring fenced for other projects
emulation to highways so all the members
and then come together they've still got
their part of 172 000. we've got the
money from sep we know it's not going to
affect the budget so and we can act
quickly so my proposal would be is that
we take the money but 172 000 pounds
from the general fund is ring fence for
highways projects
otherwise you may lose your money
should that be set related project
look I I think you know look we should
I know what Mr Holmes is saying I know
what's gone on in the past but you know
we've always you know we've always used
this money to to backfund our own
funding you know let's not make any
let's not make any things about that so
if I'm if I'm doing if I'm hearing this
correctly The Proposal is to accept the
fund and ring fence it for members to
discuss how they want it to be
um we've already agreed we've already
budgeted to do these yeah so what we do
is we go back I've got to be careful
what I say really we go back to sep and
say thank you very much these are the
three projects we're going to do take
their money and tell them we're going to
pay for those projects which we were
going to do anyway from our own general
fund we then carry EOS those three
projects through and then we actually
ring thanks the money so that we can
then use that because it's not going to
affect our budget
uh if I can have Mr Holmes to clarify
the counselor Channel
I just wanted to clarify that of the
three figures so the 137 500 is in the
budget um the 28 and the 7200 hidden so
that effectively would be new projects
that would come forward for members to
consider at some time in the future so
we basically said these are awaiting in
the wings we could use this funding for
it so what you're actually would be
doing is saying yes 137 500 is budgeted
for and that would be a saving the 28
and the 7002 are not current and not
within existing budgets so that's
slightly different to perhaps as you
described
so I mean the car parking charging
strategy I would have thought is an
operational matter which can be dealt
with in this Council I mean whatever
strategy you come forward to has to be
agreed by members so there's a good
starting point and who knows the car
parking working group might well raise
itself Like a Phoenix From the Ashes of
fixed penalty notices but you know and
the 28 000 pounds
okay uh councilor Channel then councilor
siddle thank you well actually
um Council fluke referred to general
fund I think we're talking about Capital
here regarding
um like the car parking one I've heard
what uh Mr Holmes has said about the car
parking strategy that actually did come
up in a debate when we were going
through some of the budget
considerations regarding Car parks and
there's going to be quite a lot in that
and I believe that it was agreed that
the car parking task and finish group
could be come alive again sort of rising
from the issues I guess like of Phoenix
but that could be applied still with
that strategy coming forward for members
to consider
I'm gonna I'm going to say actually I
have I will place trust in our offices I
believe they would have considered
various things that could be covered by
this significant amount of money and I
don't think they would bring anything
forward to this committee that wasn't
well considered and well thought out so
I would be supporting these
recommendations because actually
councilor Luke is right yes it was it
might have been in our Bud our budget
certain things but actually
um it's a good way of spending the money
it's a big scheme the car park surfacing
butt Lane and white horse so
um I will be supporting
um these schemes that have come forward
from officers
ah I think Mr Holmes has got a
suggestion that might might help with
this issue and I'll need Mr porches to
listen carefully and tell me if I'm
wrong
um so if effectively that that 137 is in
the council's budget if it's actually
funded by Seb and it's used for that he
does actually then release the council's
budget which could potentially be a ring
fence for other projects such as uh
other works that could be carried out
are as indicated in other around the
district is that is that correct Ms
Fortis in terms of that possibility
uh that's correct Mr harms uh
137 000 currently being funded out of
the capital receipts Reserve uh so if it
was funded from the set money that would
effectively add 137 000 back to the
capital receipts reserve for other
project capital projects
okay so that that means that we could
then decide the smaller projects as
proposed
um and not but also not risk losing any
funding okay I've got counselor
um Lagan then I got councilor Fleming is
Council Legend
just a quick couple of um observations
but one is the first thing I'd say is we
should learn about like in 1.2 there
might be a conflict of what we
understood in the past but what we can
do going forward it's not a criticism of
anybody it's just you know if we're
going to put something in a report we've
got to be Crystal Cleveland spot right
and um I do agree with the leader about
officers however people officers are
human beings and often they miss things
there might be options that come out
there where we
um can look
as members at other aspects so whilst
the leader it's obviously not interested
in my comments but
um is a look at
yeah but that's okay you know that you
do do that and um I was speaking that
way I think it's that's important to
note that also and I really get I Now
understand exactly what what sound Mr
Holmes and Mr porches are saying makes
perfect sense 3.5 says the council to
apply to use 186 000 but the total
operational Reserve to be requested is
172. and that difference what's the
reason for that difference please
the amounts that are in the current
project proposals so that's the estimate
of the car park charges and the the
other two two projects that are
currently going through projects that
have been approved as project approvals
so it's just the total of the three
projects that currently are already
approved projects and we can pull down
the additional amount um so for example
um we are undertaking some additional
Works um relating to the White Horse car
park for example so it is possible that
we could include that within the the
request so we could if essentially
um if members were agreeable we could
pull down the whole of the Surplus in
one go I would do that very much so
thank you
okay so I'll quickly go to council
siddle and then councilor Fleming and
then actually Ms Green if you can get
that proposal put into a nice parcel
then we can put that forward to the vote
okay cancer siddle my understanding is
the cardboard strategy is part of the
corporate strategy projects team so
we're looking at so we've now got
duplication the corporate projects
working group is looking at car parking
strategy so you know why why are we
getting this separate thing in terms of
a strategy now or is it because we're
going to use it to fund that the other
my other concern in terms of this is is
there's been no consultation with the
strategy team at this at the the council
um so this has truly been decided by
this by the service delivery team well I
haven't our strategy team being
consulted about it and I understand that
yeah that officers have made decisions
and I probably thought about the
decision but the whole thing about this
is the lack of imagination
yeah that that's what strikes me about
this it's a total lack of imagination of
what to do with this extra money and and
it's like and that's that's the thing
that you know I find frustrating
okay councilor Fleming
thank you chair
um yes to be frank I I was frustrated
and really disappointed not just because
of the factually incorrect statement at
1.2 just because I looked at rochford's
proposals it was actual delivery on the
ground of things that would benefit the
residents and what did we do we put in
car parking resurfacing which is already
budgeted for plus money for Consultants
and it just for me I just thought well
here we go again well you know our
default position is we get extra funding
whether it's you know whatever
fund we've and we just don't deliver on
the ground we we employ another officer
and we write another policy document and
that's why I was so disappointed with
this report
oh okay
um members so Ms Green what were you
suggesting that might give us the keep
the keep Safeguard the funding but give
us the option to use the funding for
different projects
um Madam Jimmy if it's if it's okay with
you I'd just like to to clarify that we
did consult with a strategy team and
actually Mr butcher was fully on board
and fully aware
um of these discussions and Mr butcher
has given me further information
regarding uh two of these projects that
are already going through project board
Council if it's brief yeah we need to
come to the vote on this one yeah but
I'm sure you talked about it Mr butcher
but did you talk to the about climate
change did you talk about EV did you
talk about charging did you talk about
putting those things in no
and those are all part of this what this
could be used for
um
just to clarify that our approach has
been that this funding will be used to
fund existing projects that are already
approved in our budget and in our um
projects
um portfolio so it's not bringing
forward new projects this is to fund the
existing projects that are already
approved okay councilor Swain this is
the council in the council Channel and
that's it needs to be really concise
because then we're going to the vote
like it or not that's where we are okay
Council Swain I'm concerned that there
are there are works and projects
um which
um this through sep which some of these
funds could be used for
um rather than being solely used for NDC
work
um so it we are sort of shutting off the
possibilities
Expediting a number of scpp projects
okay and cancel the channel and then we
go to the vote
um well madam chairman what I would say
is Miss green or Mrs Green I've got that
is Mrs Green I think Lance Fortress said
that
um I think she's summed it up these were
projects the council have already agreed
so that makes sense to me because we've
seen that they're important issues that
we need to do and by agreeing with these
and it will bring us um it's it's in the
report actually the implications
um it will allow provide additional
income to the council but also enabling
then the council to have the ability to
redirect the capital funding to other
Capital Council priority projects and
that's what I think we need to focus on
we you know we need to recognize there's
other capital projects that are
important that that by doing that allows
us to perhaps consider those so I'm
going to say I'm supporting the
recommendation as is madam chairman I am
so what's on the table but with the
Proviso that the
ah
so what was your proposal
and also consultation with someone from
a strategy team and also a consultation
with our set representative
um
just before we vote well there's
something else Ms Green is there any
chance of this funding being at risk
whatsoever
members um aren't quite members quiet
please this funding is at is the end of
a current
Arrangement that's been made with sep
around the Surplus distribution so
um
it is funding which because we have
moved into a new agreement will need to
be accessed at the moment there is no
immediate danger but I would say that
there was always that risk if other
important projects come forward
from other district councils there is a
risk but I wouldn't say that that's an
immediate risk
yeah exactly so my recommendation is
that the uh the working group within the
next three weeks
yeah actually members um I'm going to
possibly make an amend councilor
siddle's
um
proposal I like the idea of discussing
it through members and the set member to
decide where the money is going to be
spent but my my concern is the risks so
I'm mindful to accept the recommendation
ring fenced 137 000 and now if we have
the funding then we can discuss any
projects we want to move it on because I
don't want to risk losing that funding
because that's too much money for us to
lose
access
so I think Mr Holmes can make a uh well
the essential difference you would pull
down the one you'd pull down this amount
from um from sep you would spend that
137 000 pounds of sex money and doing
that servicing work freeing up your 137
000 of council money which you then of
course could have your working group
look at other projects to spend that on
yeah so from from the cheg
I would I would uh
okay right well if we go to councilor
siddle's vote first
yeah yeah exactly that's my concern I
remember when we lost the funding we
have lost it funding before because
other councils claimed it Madam chairman
if we agree this that's fine because
when we've got 137 freed up and that's
like I think what you're saying exactly
that can be utilized that's not the
other way around otherwise they're going
to place yourself at risk exactly we do
it the other way around as Council still
suggesting we could lose all the funding
like we have done in the past so in my
my preferred option from the chair would
be to go that we accept the funding then
distribute that the second hundred and
thirty seven thousand at no risk so if
we vote on if we vote on councilors
councilor siddle's proposal first
um and then if that's lost then we vote
on the second proposal so members all
those in favor of councilor siddle's
proposal
show of hands one two three okay that's
lost
those against sorry
one two three four five okay and okay so
um now we'll go now cancel I I move
Madam chair and we agree the
recommendations
there's been so many proposals members
short we agree with your recommendation
and that frees up 137 for them to be
considered right okay now now Council
siddles proposal issue to accept it as
it is to ring fence the 137 000 their
members can have a working group to meet
to discuss the the the where the funding
spent
just make this clear agree the
recommendations of the project and then
the other 137 freed up yes will be ring
fence for members to agree but to me
that should be on the capital projects
already done but okay cancel and
counselor and we're I'm not taking any
more proposals um but if you've just got
a very short comment Council City and
councilor Fleming really short yeah yeah
I I don't I personally do not see the
need for a feasibility study for the
additional car parking and the 7200 for
a car parking strategy so I can't agree
those okay councilor Fleming
I'm just going to say exactly the same
thing why can't we ring fence the full
amount 172 because I mean let's vote on
the proposal put forward by councilor
fluka first because we're getting bogged
down with this so members are we going
to vote on councilor fluka's motion all
those in favor
the German mine is that that we agree
the recommendation at two and then we
add another recommendation that we uh
ring ring fence the Surplus 186 000
pound which we generated I think from
the receipt fund
um for funding future projects and I
think we just leave it like that and
then we can meet you know you know do it
like we did with what we were going to
do the corporate plan yeah sort it out
with the new Administration absolutely
that sounds like a really good really
good puzzle to me exactly okay all those
in favor of councilor flukel's proposal
no I'm serious because it says we that
we um the three projects are and I
didn't I didn't think we agreed the
three projects we agreed the amount but
not the three projects
no my understanding is madam and
chairman we're agreeing the
recommendation to agree those projects
the chair yes please if I understand
correctly Mr Holmes we agree agreeing
recommendations but the cut the car park
will be funded out of the budget and so
that money won't be spent on that item
it will be ring fenced and members can
discuss at a later date how it is to be
dispersed we don't want to lose the
funding that's that's what we're coming
from I think my understanding chair is
that members are not happy about the
twenty eight thousand the seven thousand
two hundred uh that's what I read 137 I
think we've accepted that yeah we could
use the set funding for that yeah
freeing up our uh our own Capital
um to do other works with
um if members are not happy with the 28
and the 7200 as well I think they will
probably have to come back it does we
have to put something forward to Seb
um our projects we can't just say yes we
want we want that total money without
projects to back it up
um I think possibly the way to do this
is to is to claw down the 137 500
against an identified budget and perhaps
uh we could report back to members on
the two other projects that 28 and 72
because there is some justification
there is justification for asking for
those amounts and we obviously need more
detail to be able to justify those and
maybe we could do that in the next
meeting of the Saturday resources and
you could again decide and then we can
make a further approach to sep within a
month or six weeks point of order I
believe that the 28 000 the seven
thousand two hundred already in the
budget which is due to be presented to
this Council on Wednesday the 22nd of
February so the only way you could take
it out would be at that meeting I don't
believe that this this uh committee can
take that out it would have to be it
would have to be taken out at the budget
meeting chairman I I Look to Mr Fortis
to confirm but I don't believe the
twenty eight thousand the seven thousand
two hundred are in any budget at the
moment or in a Future Works program that
should be identified through the
commercial strategy so what would this
work fund was looking to do was to pull
those two projects forward out of the
commercial strategy and fund them if
members don't fund them through this
route at some point they would have come
forward to councils to say would you
please support them this is that
opportune moment so it's only the 1375
500 that is in budget that could be
replaced if you want more information on
the two other projects I suggest rather
than say no completely we get the
opportunity to come back to members you
can reconsider those projects
where are we with the proposal now then
Mr Holmes well
mine would be to agree these
recommendations as is at the term
probably but and we haven't voted on can
we've got to focus on councilor fluka's
um proposal first I think we know what
the proposal is but I think what
full support gem to the three-minute
rule thing
[Laughter]
Richard I think what Mr Holmes just said
is
the key thing we have to have a
justification to set to drawing down the
money
and we can't just take the money and say
well we bring fencer and think about it
later yeah I think uh Council Stone's
quite right that we either have to
accept this or we don't and if we don't
accept it then we're going to lose the
funding and I think what we
we have to in past we have done in the
past because other councils got him
first and they took the funding
um this
is
sorry but uh point of order I'm a bit of
clarity there the funding has already
been divided between each of the
councils that are the partners
so you will get your 186 as will
everybody else get their 186.
so there is no risk
right well remember what is the point
now we've done this either we agree this
recommendation or we don't it's quite
simple we we agree it now with the
amendment by councilor fluca or we don't
agree so let's take a vote on the
amendment by councilor fluka all those
are we in favor of Council of Luca's
motion which
just to clarify Madam chairman Council
of Luca's recommendation we agree that
recommendation for three projects yes
and then he made the additional and then
yes
um
okay all those in favor of councilor
focal's proposal please show
yeah I agree though one two three four
so one two three four five six seven all
those against
two okay well uh councilor fluka's
motion is carried
um okay
Right Moving on
um we
were trying to get that money yes
okay thank you after after all that we
finally got it okay thank you members um
right on to agenda item 18 which is
supplementary estimates violence
procurement exemptions and use of
reserves first of October to 31st
December 2022 Pages 391 to 394.
and that is Mr Porsches
no longer this who isn't it oh oh he's
back
this is the usual report that comes to
surgery and resources committee uh each
uh meeting uh all decisions have been
made in accordance with the rules and
regulations
so really it's just for noting
okay members are we happy to note that
councilor Fluker
you know obviously reports for noting no
longer come to committees but this one
is for it to be received and I think the
reason why we have these reports to
receive is so that members
um Can comment
um chairman I'd like to go 3.5.1
um chairman I presume that bear in mind
to the best of my knowledge modern
District Council only owns owns one boy
the balance of them are owned by the
Trinity house or the harbor
Commissioners so I presume we're talking
about first lit boy here
um the the procurement exemption says
that this Specialists work to be
undertaken by one contractor and that
there's no no other contractors with the
required lifting equipment capable of
undertaken the work in the river
Blackwater that is not correct uh in
fact there is a long-established company
operates on the river Blackwater who
have a shallow draft tug highly
maneuverable and it has a huge Hive on
the back and they actually do work for
Trinity house out in the Thames Estuary
um
The Operators also have smaller work
boats they have their own key they've
got the facility to lift boys out onto
their own key repair them put them back
into the water this company chairman I
can confirm to this committee were not
contacted at all and as I said they've
been in existence for a long time I
believe German if they had have been
contacted then we would know whether or
not this is a competitive quote or not
um and and I think that would put
everybody in their comfort zone so I'm
really really concerned about how the
procurement exemption came apart
I believe chairman that
I believe chairman that this contract
May well have been let I'll just look at
Mr Holmes and you might be able to let
me know if it's there's a contract being
lit Mr Holmes chairman of the work has
been completed thank you chairman if
that's the case chairman I believe that
there has been a breach of the
procurement exemption rules and that the
matter should be chairman without or
debate or with or or uh votes be
referred to the overview and scrutiny
committee thank you chairman
great thank you well that's that's been
noted
um Council wagon yeah I thank you chair
again mine's on 3.5.1 because as a
current member of the harbor
Commissioners I looked at that and
thought that's our the commissioner's
role but then I believe it's the fuzzler
boy that's there
um so if if I could ask if in the
description in the future if that's if
the detail could be put in it just
clarifies where it was actually
um from and what the work was actually
done
um and councilor fluke has raised a very
good points but thank you
Mr Holmes
um chairman I believe it was a number of
the navigation boys down the river but
just wasn't one boy
um and their Council had a
responsibility for maintaining those
particular boys and the chains needed
replacement as a matter of urgency if it
would help members I can get a full
statement and I can happily to circulate
that to members of the committee for
review we'll give you a bit more
background number of boys and the work
was actually undertaken my understanding
is this work was time limited and I
think it was about availability of
contractors at the time um regard and
maybe that statement there is not
correct but my understanding was it's a
Time limited issue but I will be more
than happy to get a sort of full
statement for the computer and share
that for your information look this is
getting worse by the moment we're now
saying it's an emergency yet the report
doesn't speak to an emergency
nevertheless there this talks to the
fact that it's only one person that can
undertake this work I also believe
there's somebody on the North Bank of
the river that should be concerned this
is a failure of procurement of this
local Authority now we this committee I
don't think it's up to this committee to
to look at such failures I think that's
the role of the overview and scrutiny
committee so I think chairman my
proposal is is that the matter of the
procurement exemption in this particular
matter is referred to the overview and
scrutiny committee as clearly something
is not I think Council thank you for
Luca that is down to you to report to
the ovian security committee and not the
um the committee as a whole well
chairman I if that's the case then
German I I will use this moment to say
that I'm going to raise a formal
complaint against I think it's a direct
to a strategy performance and governance
for signing this off thank you okay
thank you Council speaker that's noted
and I'm sure the officers will be
hearing from you okay agenda item 19 any
other items in business the chairman of
committee decides are urgent we do have
one
um there is one but given it's a
confidential item of business it will be
considered in private session following
a gender item uh 21. all right so you've
got a gender item 20
um I I move that the committee resolves
the under Section 108 little four of the
Local Government Act 1972 the public be
excluded from the meeting for the
following items of business on the
grounds that they involve the likely
disclosure of exempt information are
designed in paragraph uh 20 and from a
report of this Committee of schedule 12a
to the ACT and that this satisfies the
public interest test do I have a
proposal
thank you seconder thank you councilor
Swain and thank you I'll now invite
numbers to make any comments on the
report so agenda